in this beginner's course you will learn
how to create an android app from rahul
pandy rahul is an android engineer at
facebook and a lecturer at stanford
university we're going to build an
android app from the very beginning
we'll start with an empty project and
end with something you can actually use
and even publish to the play store we're
going to build a tip calculator where
you can enter in a base amount tip
percentage and the app will calculate
the tip and total amount for you
we're going to build this app using the
kotlin programming language so i'm going
to assume you have some background in
programming but if you're new to kotlin
i'll leave a link in the description to
a quick 12-minute primer about the
language i made
i'm rahul i've been teaching android on
youtube and off youtube for a while now
so when you're ready let's get into it
and build this app together
[Music]
there are three things i want to cover
in this video number one i want to walk
through the main features of the tip
calculator application number two i will
explain the core android concepts we'll
cover while building it and third
because i'm keeping the app deliberately
very simple i also want to call out some
of the android concepts that we won't
encounter while building it and those
will be
covered in more sophisticated or
complicated android apps later on
i mentioned earlier how you could
actually go ahead and publish this app
on the google play store as soon as you
finish finish the tutorial and that's
exactly what i did so if you want to try
out what we're going to build then feel
free to check out the link in the
description um and download on one of
your android devices
so let's do a demo of the app so we can
get a sense of the main features that
we're going to build so in this example
i went out for a very lavish solo dinner
and i spent 83.15
and i'm leaving a pretty generous tip of
24
and the apple automatically compute the
tip and total amount
so just to make the math a little bit
easier why don't we update the base
amount to be 100 and what you can see is
the keyboard that comes up
only allows us to input numbers and
decimals which makes sense because we're
dealing with currencies here
and
if i'm feeling really happy with the
service i received at the meal i could
increase the tip percentage and bring it
to the maximum amount to 30
and two things happen here one is that
we dynamically update the tip and total
amount computation so 30 and the sum is
130 but also we update the description
of that tip percentage so it went from
great to amazing and also became this
brighter green color
on the other hand if i was really
unhappy with the service i might tip
zero and we consider that a poor tip
and you can see how the color got
updated to this red color
and then at the bottom here in the
footer we also have a way to personalize
the app so you can say
who made it or where you're from
the concepts we cover in the tip
calculator are the same concepts that
are fundamental to every android app
first is creating the ui every app needs
a user interface and the core component
we'll leverage here is the constraint
layout which will contain the other
widgets for example the text view or the
seek bar to enter in the tip percentage
second every interesting android app is
going to listen and react to user input
so we have two ways of inputting data in
our app one is entering in the base
amount and second is a tip percentage
and based on that we need to react and
update the ui appropriately
and third we will barely scratch the
surface of styling an animation on
android i'll show you how to update some
of the colors and also show you how to
do an animation with the tip description
and change its color dynamically
there's also a lot that we're not going
to cover in the tip calculator and
that's important in order to reduce
scope and make this app really quick and
simple to
to build if you're new to android
first we're not going to have multiple
screens
which means that we don't have to deal
with things like navigation or the back
stack in android and in fact the single
screen that we do have is actually quite
simple because we don't have
any kind of list data that we need to
manage
second we have nothing to do with
networking and the internet as soon as
you start talking to an api or a server
things become quite a bit more
complicated because you have to deal
with asynchronous programming and
managing that data
and third we're also not dealing at all
with storage everything it will be local
and in memory so we're not going to
write to a database or to disk or to the
cloud anywhere and all three of these
make the app much simpler uh to build
so i'm sure when you build this and you
walk into a restaurant you're going to
be super popular because you'll be able
to compute the tip really easily and
literally your name will be on the app
so i will see you in the next video
[Music]
in this video we're going to start with
the brand new android studio project and
lay out the views for our tip calculator
in particular we're going to lay out
eight views where the four text views on
the left will describe the contents of
what is being shown on the right
the first thing we'll do is create a
brand new android studio project so i
have inner studio running here and i'm
running arctic fox but any recent
version should do tap on new project and
i'm going to pick the empty activity
template these other ones are useful
sometimes but they bring in a lot of
cruft into our application which could
be confusing so usually i'll just go
with empty activity
let's call our application tippy
the package name usually what i'll do is
i'll take my domain name or my email
address and flip it backwards so i'll
leave that as is and then pick a
location make sure you have kotlin
select as language and i'm going to pick
minimum sdk version as api 21 now i'll
tap on finish
and the very first thing i like to do
whenever i have a brand new project is
simply try and run the starter code
because if we can't even run the starter
code then something's already gone wrong
let's make sure that we're at a known
good place before we start writing any
code
when we create a new project android
studio will take some time to set
everything up to run our application we
can go to the drop down in the menu and
choose to deploy our app either to an
emulator or a physical device so i'm
going to choose pixel 2 api 29 which is
an emulator i created from before
hit that green triangle to boot up our
emulator if it doesn't already exist and
then
build and deploy our project to this
emulator and you'll see the status at
the bottom of android studio to see the
current progress this might take a
minute or two
but when it's done the app will get
automatically sent to the device and
brought to the foreground so all we need
to do is wait until we see some action
on the emulator
okay great this looks promising we are
seeing an application called tippy show
up in the emulator with the text of
hello world which is a default for an
empty project and this gives us
confidence that we are able to
successfully run the basic project let's
come into android studio and spend a
quick minute talking about the starter
files and actually it's quite simple
because there are only two files that
we're going to be concerned with
mainactivity.kotlin
and
activitymain.xml
you can think of an activity in android
terminology as representing one screen
so with the project that we have right
now we only have one screen and that's
referred to as the main activity or the
main screen
and that's the business logic
that we're defining right here in this
file called main activity
in particular the starter code gives us
one function or one method that is
already being overwritten and that's
called oncreate so the android system
will automatically invoke or call this
function when our application is
starting up when it's creating our
screen
and the important line here is line nine
set content view r dot layout
directivity main so r stands for
resources so what we're saying here is
that the content or the ui of our screen
should be the layout file in resources
defined at activitymain.xml and indeed
if we jump to the definition
of this we can see that goes directly to
activitymain.xml
so i'm going to minimize the project
tool window over here to give a give
ourselves more room and let's also
minimize the attributes pane so here's
exactly what we're seeing in the
application just a blank canvas with
hello world and in particular if you
look at the component tree over here it
might be minimized for you but you can
expand it by tapping over here
we can see the parent element is
something called a constraint layout and
it has exactly one child called a text
view or a label
and that has an attribute which has
value hello world and that's how we're
seeing the hello world text in our
running application in this video we're
going to spend all our time in activity
main.xml because we're only concerned
right now with constructing the ui for
our application and in particular here
is how we want to end we're going to
have eight components in the screen on
the left we have four different text
views you can think of a text view like
a label which isn't editable by the user
on the right we have the actual
components being described by the text
view so we have a edit text at the top
which allows the user to enter in a bill
amount
we have a seek bar which allows the user
to enter a tip percentage and then two
more text views at the bottom for the
tip and total amount
there's one more thing i want to call
out before we start constructing our
layout which is that there are multiple
perspectives of our ui what we're
looking at by default is the design
preview which is what will actually show
up on your emulator or device but you
can also drop down into the code tab
which is the actual underlying xml so
you can see how we have the constraint
layout and then one child view the text
view same as design split means you look
at both and most of our time is going to
be spent looking at the design preview
and what we can do is go into the
palette and drag and drop different
components like a texture or edit text
that we want and again that will be
represented in the code tab so just keep
that in mind that there is a one-to-one
correspondence between whatever changes
you make in the design preview and the
underlying xml so for now let's go back
to design
delete whatever components we have so we
have a single constraint layout with no
children the documentation describes
constraint layout as a way to create
large and complex layouts with the flat
view hierarchy
we're able to describe the relationship
between sibling views and parent layouts
through a set of constraints that we
define and that allows the android
system to gracefully
lay out our ui across phones or tablets
of multiple sizes and the important
thing here is no nested view groups on
android if you have a very deeply nested
view hierarchy that leads to a lot of
performance degradation and something
that we call jank or ui lag
and so the constraint layout allows us
to create complex views without having
nested view groups
coming back to the tip calculator
project we're going to lay out all eight
views on screen here in a single parent
constraint layout there will be no
nested view groups which is as good as
we can get there are no relative layouts
or linear layouts inside of our parent
constraint layout so even if you've
never worked with the constraint layout
before take a moment right now to think
about how might you position the views
on screen here relative to one another
such that we can describe it in a flat
view hierarchy
back in android studio the first thing
we'll do is drag out
a text view representing the top left
component of our screen which is the
text view representing the base label
the first thing i need to do whenever i
drag out any component is update the id
to be something more meaningful so i'll
call this tv base label
and then update the text to be base
and what you'll notice here is that
android studio is complaining that this
text view is missing constraints
so it only has design time positions
it'll jump to position 0 0 which is the
top left of the screen at run time
unless we add constraints and this is
the whole point of the constraint layout
we have to constrain every component
vertically and horizontally so
vertically what we'll do is drag this
top anchor point of the
tv base label and drag it to the top of
the screen
and then in the attributes tab we will
specify the margin of how far away we
want it from the top of the screen and
i'm going to say 48 from the top
similarly we want to specify a left
margin so we'll drag the left anchor
point and drag it to the parent and
specify this to be 32 dp away from the
left end of the screen
so now you can see the error went away
we're going to do
the same process now for the other three
text views on the left side of the
screen so starting with the one right
below the base label is a tv tip percent
label
also the text here to be 24
the text view below that will be the tv
tip label
the text will be tip
and then finally we'll have the tv total
label
and the text here will be
total
so we have the same issue where we have
to constrain all of these horizontally
and vertically vertically what we'll do
is take the top anchor point for each
textview and drag it to the component
above it and we'll specify a margin of
32dp which means that each textview
should lift 32 pixels or 32dp below the
textview above it so we'll drag the top
anchor point
and drag it to the bottom anchor point
of the text view above it and again do
the same thing 32 dp
that constrains each of these views
vertically now how about horizontally if
you go back to the desired end state
what you'll notice is that if we draw a
vertical line here all of the components
on the left side they will all be
aligned to the right end of that top
textview this tv base label so that is
how we want to constrain them
horizontally and we could actually do
this in the design tab we could say
align and then align the right edges
but i'd like to show you how to do this
in the code tab so if i open up the code
tab like we talked about every change
you make in the design tab has a
corresponding change in the code tab so
right now we have four text views and
that's exactly what we can see here we
have one two
three four
like we talked about there's right now
an error in that we are not constraining
these horizontally that's why we have
this red underline
the vertical constraint is what you can
see here
so what we're communicating with this
line is at the top
of the tv tip percent label should be
exactly equal to the bottom of the tv
base label which is a text view above it
along with a margin of 32 dp which means
we want it to be 32 pixels below the
component above it so similarly what we
want to do is specify
that the end of this component the tv
tip percent label should be equal to the
end of the tv base label
and we want this to be applied to each
of the components on the left side
so with that you can see how that error
went away if you go back to the design
tab you can see how everything is now
aligned
one more thing
i want to call out here is that the
tool's namespace is only used for the
purpose of rendering the design preview
because we have now fully constrained
each of these views horizontally and
vertically we don't actually need this
anymore so i'm going to
select each of these
and delete it
and one more thing is i'm pretty big on
having a consistent style and ordering
of the different attribute names so for
example here we have the ending angle
bracket on the same line or new line and
to fix that automatically for us i can
tap double shift and then just search
for reformat
and there's a shortcut for reformatting
the code if i do that then you can see
how android studio helped us to fix it
up
across the whole file
which i like a lot more
okay so let's go back into the design
tab and before we move on to the
components on the right side of the
screen one thing i want to do is just a
few quick design tweaks first
i want to make the text a little bit
bigger here so i'm going to make the
text appearance medium
so you can see how that made it bigger
and then this
tv tip percent label is a bit unique
because it's representing the value of
what tip percent the user actually chose
so to indicate that it's a little bit
different from the others i'm going to
make the text bold here
cool i like that now let's think about
the four components on the right end of
the screen this one is going to be edit
text below that we have a seek bar and
then below that we have two text views
so
let's
drag out a edit text and the one we'll
drag is the one which says number
decimal
and the difference between all these
different edit texts is actually quite
simple it's simply the input type
because we're dealing with the currency
we want numbers and decimals in hours
um below this we are going to have
a seek bar
and then below that
we're going to drag out two text views
all right let's update the ids here to
be something more sensible so this is
going to be called
et
base amount
all right next we have the seek bar
tip
then we have tv
tip amount
and then finally we have the tv total
amount
let's update the text here to be 103.11
and this one
i think we said 1996.
let's do some design tweaks before we
position these elements so these bottom
text views these are the most important
part of the whole app so i'm going to
make the text large
the seek bar i'm going to specify a
hard-coded width of 200 dp
to make it a little bit wider
and then also there's an attribute here
called max which is the maximum amount
that the seek bar will hold and that'll
be 30 because we only allow up to thirty
percent
for the
edit text i'm going to set the ems to be
eight which means how many characters
why how many characters wide will this
edit text be and eight is sufficient for
us
i'm going to increase the text size to
be
24 sp
and then finally i'm going to add a hint
here or a placeholder which is the bill
amount so the user knows what this edit
text is for
now let's think about how to position
these so vertically
the bottom two textview should be
aligned vertically so i'm going to
select both of them and then
align the vertical centers and similarly
for the
ones above those
and then similarly for the tip percent
and the square
and you can see how in the design tab
we're actually able to see this nice
preview of the constraints which are
added
for the bill amount let's think about
how to constrain it horizontally it'll
be 32 dp away from the corresponding
text view on the left side
and
horizontally all the other components on
the right side these bottom three should
be aligned to the left end of the bill
amount
edit text so i'm going to select all of
them and i'm going to
specify the left edges should all be
aligned that looks good the only thing
we have to do now is if we hover over
here
we are missing a vertical constraint on
the edit text so to do that i'm going to
go into the code tab
here's the edit text et bass mount and
the way we'll communicate the vertical
positioning is by considering the top of
this element to the top of the top left
view which is a tv base label and
similarly the bottom of this view should
also be the bottom of the tv base label
so it'll be right in the middle
vertically so if you go back to the
design tab you can see that now the
errors have gone away and you can see
visually what these constraints look
like
if you go back to the design tab again
we don't need this tool's namespace
anymore because we are fully
constraining everything let's reformat
the code really fast
and then one more thing i want to do is
even though
this is not needed for the purposes of
running the program just for the sake of
developer information i'd like to label
these with a comment so these are the
views on the left side
and then after four text views starting
with the edit text these are the views
on the right side
let's try it to see what this looks like
okay awesome like we'd expect this is
pretty much exactly mirroring what we
see in the design preview the only thing
that i want to fix up here or improve is
that it's a little bit weird that we
already have values for the tip and
total amount even though the user hasn't
actually entered anything and that's
exactly what the purpose of the tools
namespace is that we talked about
earlier so what i'll do is select
the
corresponding text view and rather than
having a text here i'm going to scroll
down
i'm going to move this over into the
ranch text area and that's the tools
namespace so i'm going to move these
over
into the tools text
and then finally the same thing over
here
so just to show you what that did if you
go back to the code tab
if you look at the tv tip percent label
now instead of having the android text
attribute it's now the tools text
attribute and if we run the app one last
time
let's see the impact this has on the
initial layout
awesome this looks pretty good hopefully
this video gave you a good sense of the
power of the constraint layout one thing
i can show you just to demonstrate what
we've done is that with these eight
views on the screen they're all located
instead of a single parent and if i drag
out that top left text view everything
moves according to that which is a
really nice way of relatively
constraining all the views to each other
so the job in the next video is
actually to hook up the business logic
in the main activity so we can react to
the input and compute the tip and total
amount see you in the next video
in the last video we laid out the eight
views on screen for our tip calculator
application
in this video we want to add the
business logic to actually make our app
interactive
what we like to be able to do is when
the user scrubs on the
seek bar we want to update the tip
percent label and when they enter in a
base amount
then we want to take that value and then
compute the tip and total amount in
particular you'll notice that there is
no submit button so as soon as the user
changes the base amount or the tip
percent we want to dynamically compute
the tip and total amount
when anything changes
so as a first exercise what i want to be
able to do is as soon as the user
changes the value on the seek bar i want
to be able to update the tip percent
label
so in android studio the first thing
we'll do is get a reference to the views
on the screen that we actually need to
be able to read data from or modify and
there are actually five different
widgets on the screen that we care about
the tip percent label and then all four
of the components on the right side of
the screen so in android studio
the way we'll do this is declare a bunch
of variables up here
for each of the components so for
example we have the edit text
that'll be etbase amount and the type of
this is going to be type edittext but
don't worry too much about the syntax
here if it's confusing all we're saying
is this is a private variable
it's
a late initialization because we're
going to initialize it inside of the
oncreate method and not in the
constructor which is why it's late
initialization it's a variable and that
we're calling it etbase mount the
convention i follow that the name of the
variable is exactly equal to the name of
the id so now in the oncreate after the
set content view we are going to
say etbase amount find view by id
r.id
et bass amount
and we're going to repeat this now for
the other four
components on the screen
so we have a seek bar tip
and the type here is seek bar
and then we have tv tip percent
that's going to be a text view
and then we have two more text views
one is tv
tip amount
and the other is tv total amount
now i'll just pull out references to all
these inside of oncreate
and finally we have the
total amount
so coming back to our objective the
first thing we want to do is when the
user scrubs on the seek bar we want to
be notified of changes of that user
input and then update the tv tip percent
label to indicate that
so actually let me
update the name of the variable here
just be tv tip percent label for
consistency
wait and the way we get notified of
changes on the seekbar is by adding a
listener on it so we'll say seekbartip
dot
set on seekbar change listener
and now we need to
tell the android system what should
happen when the sequari's changed and
the syntax here is we're going to say
object
seekbar dot
on square change listener and then we're
going to define this class inside here
and another will help us implement this
you'll have this red underline under
object to tap on the red light bulb and
tap on implement numbers there are three
methods that we have to override in
order to
comply with the definition of this on
seekbar change listener
and energy will help us with that and
don't worry too much again if the syntax
is confusing the details here are that
we are defining an anonymous class which
implements this interface so if i go to
the definition here you can see that
this is a public interface which has
those three methods exactly that we have
overwritten and now it's our job to tell
the system what should be happening when
each of these methods are called
and actually we don't really care about
on start tracking touch or on stop
tracking touch so i'm going to remove
the 2ds here and just leave an empty
implementation
before we update the ui let's first add
a log statement in android to more
easily figure out what's going on so
i'll write log.i and this is a method
that takes in two parameters the first
one is a string which i'll call tag i'll
define later and the second one is also
a string which is a message of our log
statement and i'll say on progress
changed which is a method name along
with the progress which is the current
value of the seek bar
so let's define this tag
i'm going to go up to the top of the
class and define a private const val
tag and the convention here is that
whenever you have any kind of logging
the tag is typically going to be the
class name
all right let's run it
so the idea here is that every time the
progress is changed on the seek bar
which means the user is scrubbing we'll
print out the current value shown
in logcat which is where the logs get
outputted so let's open up logcat open
up the emulator and the logs that we
care about are the ones from only our
application which is com com rk pandey
tippy
and we also only care about info level
logs because that is what log.i
represents info level logs
we also only care about logs which have
this particular tag which is main
activity so let's add main activity as a
filter
and here as we change the seek bar we
can see how we get one line of logcat
outputted and it represents exactly what
is the current indicator of the seat bar
showing so if we go all the way up to
the maximum we see 30 as we expect and
if we come all the way back down we go
to zero
so now let's update the ui and in
particular we want to update the tv tip
percent label to indicate the current
progress of the seek bar so we'll say tv
to percent label the text attribute of
that we'll set that equal to the
progress but actually we want the
progress to be
represented as a string not an int and
also we want to concatenate a percent
sign after it so we'll say dollar sign
progress which is how we do string
interpolation in kotlin
similar to what we did in a log
statement and then add a percent sign at
the end
let's try it
so as we scrub on the seekbar you can
see how the tv tip percent label does
get updated in lockstep with the current
progress of the sequar which is great
one improvement here though is that
initially
we are not indicating any tip percent in
the label and so to fix that
let's define one more constant which
we'll call
initial tip percent so we'll have a
private const val initial tip percent
and we'll set that equal to 15. so
initially the default tip is going to be
15
so with that define as a constant before
we do anything in the listener right in
the oncreate method will say
seekbartip.progress
is equal to initial tip percent
and we also want to update the label
appropriately so we'll say tv tip
percent label dot text is equal to
initial tip percent with the percent
sign after
now when we run the app we should see
instead of the blank tip percent label
we should see 15 like we do and the
progress bar indicator is exactly in the
middle of the width of the whole seat
bar
next similar to how we are able to react
to changes in the seek bar we also want
to be able to react to changes in the
edit text
so
there's a analogous method on the et
bass mount we'll call
add text change listener
and the syntax will be similar we pass
in an object here which is an anonymous
class is an implementation of the text
watcher
and we'll have android studio help us
once again there are some methods that
we have to override so i'm going to tap
on the red light bulb and implement the
members there are three
override all them and then similar to
before the only thing that we care about
is after text change so i'm going to go
ahead and delete
the body of the implementation here
and just to get a better understanding
of what's happening here again let's add
a log statement say after
text changed
dollar sign us
all right let's try it so dollar sign s
is the parameter passed in and that is
actually what the user is
typing at that moment
let's run this let's open up logcat once
again
okay so like before if i modify the
seekbar you can see that it is changing
appropriately and then if i
add a value into the
edit text you can see eight zero zero it
is being updated appropriately in logcat
two quick notes first i sometimes see
students will get tripped up when they
invoke functions in kotlin the msg that
you're seeing when we call log.i is a
hint from android studio about what that
parameter represents so if you actually
type msg that will lead to a compiler so
just make sure you don't do this second
i want to demystify what the object
keyword means so these object
expressions like we're using twice so
far are examples of how to create
anonymous classes which are one-time use
classes that are commonly used to
implement interfaces so we have both
text watcher and on sql change listener
as interfaces defined by the android
system and these methods that we're
overriding will automatically be invoked
for us when the user takes the
appropriate action on the underlying
edit text or seek bar
so now we have all the ingredients in
place to actually make this app
functional whenever the edit text
changes i'm going to
call a method called compute tip and
total and this is actually what will
take the values from the edit text and
seek bar
and then update the tip and total amount
appropriately
so this method doesn't exist yet but
again let's leverage the utility of
android studio and have industrial
create this function for us inside of
main activity
and there are a couple things that have
to happen in this method first we want
to get the value of the base and tip
percent
second we'd like to compute the tip and
total
and third we need to update the ui to
show those values
so to get the value of the base and tip
that's pretty straightforward we just
look at the add attack so et bass amount
grab the text
and then call to string on it and then
on the string we know it's going to be a
currency like a decimal so we'll call
two double on it
in order to
turn it into a number that we can work
with and we'll call this base amount
and then similarly for the tip percent
we want to get the value of the progress
on the seek bar there's an attribute
called progress and that'll be saved in
a variable that i'm going to call tip
percent
okay next we want to compute the tip and
total amount
so the tip amount is going to be the
base amount
times the tip percent
divided by 100. so for example if the
base amount is
a hundred dollar i went out for 100 meal
and the tip percent is 20 then
i expect the tip amount to be 20
so that'll be 20 divided by 100 is 20
times 100 and that gives me 20 so
that'll be tip amount
and then we have the total amount and
the total amount is simply going to be
the base amount
plus the tip
amount okay finally we need to update
the ui and again this turns out to be
pretty straightforward because we have a
reference to the two text views which
show the tip and total amount which is
tv chip amount and we're going to set
the text attribute there to be tip
amount
and this is going to throw an error
because tip amount is a number it's a
double right but we actually require
something called a car sequence
and to give it a card sequence we can
just call to string on this value
and then similarly we call we need to
say tb total amount set the text
attribute here
to be the total amount to string
and this should be a plus sign
okay this is the whole brain of our
application
so if we run this then what we're doing
is anytime that the
edittext value has changed we're going
to call this method and we should be
updating the ui to have the correct
amount for the tip and total amount
all right so we have 15 for the tip if i
add in 100 here then you do see
immediately we get the correct tip and
total computation and we would like to
have the same
logic get executed if i change the
seek bar the tip percent and that turns
out to be really easy because we've
abstracted all the logic away into this
method so i'm going to call compute tip
and total right here in on progress
changed
all right so if we try this now
we should have a pretty functional app
okay so similar to before if i put in
100 here we do correctly compute 115 and
if i change the
tip percent you can see it does
appropriately get updated all right so
this is working actually pretty well but
there are two things that i think are
incorrect or could be improved so just
take a moment right now think about what
are two improvements that you could do
to the app that we have right now try
playing around with it see if you can
identify any issues
okay so the first
improvement that we can make is actually
a bug so
notice what will happen now if i
backspace
on the base amount
so that there's nothing there so you can
see the app actually crashed
so if we look at logcat let's take a
look at what actually was the error so
i'm going to scroll up to the very top
of the stack trace
and you can see here we have a number
format exception this is the important
part there's an empty string and and the
stack trace tells us exactly where the
issue happened is on main activity 958
and so the issue that's happening is
that when the edit text has an empty
value then it doesn't make sense to
try and convert an empty string into a
double
the very first thing we should be doing
here is actually checking if et
baseamount
dot text if that is
empty then we need to do an earlier turn
additionally we should be clearing out
the values of the tv tip and total
amount because if the edit text is empty
that means there's nothing to tip on and
we should be showing nothing for those
two textures then we call return so that
none of the rest of the function will
get executed
the second improvement we'll make is
about formatting the output of the tip
and total amount so it's not that
noticeable when we enter in 100 for the
base amount but if we add in 100.9 then
you can see that the total amount
becomes very long and unwieldy
because we're dealing with currency we
should really be mandating that there
are exactly two decimal points in both
the tip and total amount and the way
we'll do that is right here instead of
just calling to string we want to format
this string before we put it into the
text view
so the way we do that is by using this
format method so we define the format
like this percent.2f which means we only
want two
numbers after after the decimal point
dot format
and we pass in the tip amount
and then similarly for the total amount
say percent.2f
format
let's try it
so hopefully now
in this scenario we should actually end
up with 116.04
instead of this very long decimal
so when i type in 100 right away you can
see instead of only having one decimal
point now we have two and the true test
is when i type in 100.9
now
the display of this is way better we
have 116.04 rather than that huge
decimal which becomes
unreadable
so at this point we have a very
functional app what we've done is gotten
references to the relevant views on the
layout and then added listeners to the
seek bar into the edit text because
there's no submit button anytime there's
any change in the seek bar or the edit
text we are dynamically computing the
tip and total amount and then updating
the views appropriately in this compute
tip and total amount so in the next
video what i want to show you is
some style improvements along with a way
to personalize it and add a really cool
animation
i'll see you in the next one
at this point we're done with the
implementation of our tip calculator
in this video our goal is to add some
color animation and personalization into
the app so we'll start off with the
footer at the bottom a lot of apps or
websites have this where it says you
know made with love in california or
made with love by this person so we're
going to start off by adding a text view
at the bottom of the screen so let's go
into internet studio
open up the activity main.xml and scroll
down to the bottom and we're going to
drag out one text view here
let's give it an id of tv footer
and then the text will be made
with
love by rahul and of course you can
personalize this however you want
um
to constrain it we're going to
have this horizontally be in the center
of the screen so we're going to add a
left and right constraint to make it
centered and then we're going to make it
32
dp from the bottom of the screen
i also want to add a couple different
style tweaks here first is all caps i
want to make everything here
capitalized
and i want to change the font
to be
sans-serif condensed light
and then finally i want to
make this a little bit larger
text appearance
medium
okay and finally i want to change the
love word with the emoji and you can
either add this to your keyboard or
another way to do this is if you just
google for heart emoji then the first
result that comes up gives me an option
here to copy and paste the emoji
paste that in
and it looks a little bit weird in the
preview but
it does show up properly when you render
it in the design and if we check it out
in the app
awesome that looks
pretty good
the next thing i like to do is update
the color scheme so we move away from
these default status bar color color
primary in this background white so let
me explain where these colors are coming
from
there's one very important file that
must exist in every single android app
and that's called the android manifest
file so if you open that up
then this file describes all the
different components of your application
the permissions for example if your app
needs internet permission
and
much more and the important line for us
is right here on line 11 where we're
describing the theme of our application
and this is a file that automatically
gets created for us when we create the
empty project so i'm going to jump to
the definition here and you'll see you
have two different files here one for
normal theme and one for night theme and
the one that we're currently looking at
is normal i'm going to open that up and
this is where we're getting the colors
for
the default application that we have so
in order to update the colors we're
going to have to define
new colors and then replace them here we
can take a look at where this file lives
by hitting this option select open file
and we can see that it lives inside of
resources values and a themes directory
and the colors are also defined inside
of color xml in the values directory and
each of the colors is defined as a
hexadecimal value purple 500 and so on
so our job is let's figure out what
colors we want and then add them here
and then we'll reference them inside of
the themes xml file
so in order to figure out what colors
you want there's a couple different
options i'll show you what i typically
do if you go to color.adobe.com
there's this really nice tool where you
figure out what kind of color scheme you
want so there's a couple different
options here you can
pick the color harmony rule analogous
monochromatic triad and so on once
you're happy with something then you can
scroll down and grab the hexadecimal
values here
so i did this exercise already and here
are the colors i came up with i'm going
to have one which is called primary blue
darker blue and background blue so let's
go ahead
into the colors xml and define these
so the first one is going to be called
primary blue
and that has
this value
the next one is background blue or the
next one is darker blue
and then finally we have background blue
so now in themes xml i updated the color
primary to be
primary blue
and then i updated the primary variant
to be darker blue and that's going to be
the color of the status bar
and then finally in order to have a
background color on the whole app i'm
going to add one more attribute here
which is called background color android
color background
and that is going to be the background
blue that we have let's try it
awesome that looks great so we're
getting very close now
to the desired end state we have the
footer and we have the customized color
the last thing i want to talk about is
this animation on the tip description
and here's actually what this looks like
as the user is scrubbing we will
dynamically update the color of that
word that's used to describe the current
tip percentage and it'll go from
red if it's a very bad tip to a really
bright green if it's really good tip not
only that but we're also going to be
changing that word or that adjective
used to describe the tip percentage so
it gives the user some really nice
interactive feedback about what kind of
tip they're leaving
okay so the first thing we'll do is
let's add a text view beneath the seek
bar and increase the vertical distance
between these two text views so
close out these other
editor windows because we don't need to
look at them again in activity main
what we'll do is first increase the
distance between the 24 which is the 10
percent label and the
tv tip label so let's increase the
margin here to be 56.
next let's drag out one more text view
and we'll call this
tv tip description
and then the text should be empty
because that will depend on the initial
tip percent which is set
programmatically but to get a better
sense of what this might look like
we are going to use the tools namespace
and just say acceptable here
that looks good and now we need to
position this horizontally and
vertically so vertically it's going to
be right below
the
seek bar tip bar and we'll add a margin
here of maybe 8 dp
and then we want these two to be
horizontally aligned
a horizontal center great and you can
see how it added the
left and right constraints so it'll be
right in the middle and you can see the
error also went away
so now back in main activity we need to
get a reference to that text view
so say
the id
here was tv tip description so we're
going to say tv tip description get a
reference to it here
and every time the
c fires change that is where we have the
potential now to update the language on
that
text view so i'm going to have one more
method here called update
tip description
and let's have entertainer help us to
create this because this method doesn't
exist yet
and one thing we'll do actually is as a
parameter into the update
description method i'd like to pass in
the progress int so progress
and again android video can now help us
to add this as a parameter into
the function that we
have defined
so tap that red light bulb
and have enrolled help us to add the
parameter and all it did here is i just
added a parameter
and instead of calling it progress i'm
going to call it
tip
percent and it's of type int
so now the idea is that based on the
value of tip percent we'd like to be
able to say tvtip
description.text and we'd like to be
able to set it to
you know be something like good and of
course this good will change
based on the value and the construct in
kotlin to be able to
decide a value of something based on a
set of conditionals is called when which
is similar to switch in java
so i'm going to say val tip description
is equal to when and then depending on
the value of two percent
we'll take certain action so if tip
description if tip percent is between 0
and 9
then
the
string should be poor
if it's between 10 and 14
we'll call it
acceptable between 15 and 19
it'll be
good
and when it's between
20 and
24
it'll be great
and there should be one extra period in
here
and finally
anything else meaning that the value is
above 24
then we'll say amazing
and so now instead of using good here
we'll just say tip description
and finally before we test this out one
more thing i want to do is
at the very beginning when we are
setting up our screen which is you know
in the oncreate method as soon as we get
all the
references to each of the views we also
would like to call that method
update tip description right here with
the initial tip percent just so that the
language is always going to be in sync
with what we start out with
let's try it
so now hopefully we should see a text
view right underneath the seek bar and
the
text on in that text view should change
according to what we have selected
through the seek bar
okay this looks promising already
because
initially the tip percent is 15 which
means we fall into this branch of the
when statement and that means that the
value should be good that's good and
then if we
bring it down to zero we get poor and if
we go all the way up we should get
amazing which we do one quick thing i
want to do is back in activity main i
want to set the
font weight of this to be bold
so the text style should be bold to make
it stand out a little bit more
finally the last thing i want to show is
this interactive color animation where
if the user picks a very good tip we
show bright green and if the user picks
a bad dip then we show a red color
indicating something went wrong coming
back into android studio in
mainactivity.kotlin update tip
description is where we're going to add
the logic for updating the color based
on the tip percent
the question is how do we dynamically
compute a color based on an integer the
way we'll do this is through a concept
called interpolation which is actually a
fancy word for something which is
conceptually quite simple
if i tell you i'm running 100 miles and
i'm 75 of the way done then you would
tell me that i'm roughly at the 75 mile
mark and what you're doing in your head
is linear interpolation you're assuming
i'm going at a constant speed starting
at zero ending at 100 and therefore i'm
at 75 miles
the same thing is exactly applying here
every color can be represented as
integer so if i'm tipping 20 percent
then we're two-thirds of the way between
the very worst color and the very best
color which are two integers and all we
need to do is some simple math in order
to compute what exactly that color value
is for the tip description
the first thing we'll do is define the
color for the worst and best tip so open
up color xml and let's add in color
worth tip color best tip and i picked a
red and
green color like we talked about so
we're going to paste these values in for
color worse and color best
so we have these defined
and now our job is simply to do some
math at 0 we should show word step at 30
we should show the best tip and
everything else is some value in between
and this turns out to be so common that
android actually has something called a
rgb evaluator to help with this where we
represent colors as integer values a
stands for alpha rgb is red green blue
and it will help compute the color for
us
so coming back into
main activity
we're going to define a color
and that will be coming from argb
evaluator
dot evaluate
and then this takes in three parameters
one is the fraction of where are we on
this
progress bar between 0 and 30. second is
start value which is the very worst
color and the end value is the best
color so the fraction is simply going to
be
the tip percent which is the perimeter
passed in
divided by the
maximum amount of tip which is 30 and
that's going to be
cprtip.max
next we need to get the very worst color
and the way we'll do that is context
compat dot get color
pass in this which is referring to the
contact and then the actual color that
we just defined in the colors xml which
is color worst tip
and then finally
we're going to provide the best color
here
[Music]
one issue you'll notice is that there's
a type mismatch we require a float but
we found integer so by default because
both the numerator and denominator are
integers we're going to do some sort of
truncation which we don't want so the
way to handle this is to cast one of the
numerator or denominator to a float
value and that will resolve that so now
we have this color all we need to do is
set the color on the
tip description text view set text color
with the color
and finally before before we try this we
need to cast the result of the evaluate
function call to be an integer because
we know
the values were computing between our
integers so the color should be an int
and now we should be able to compile and
run this just fine
so two things should happen now one is
we should bold the
text and second there should be a color
applied immediately
and based on what percent we pick it
should adapt as well okay this looks
good so initially we have
a color right in between the green and
red and if i go all the way down to zero
you can see how it changes to red and if
i
scrub upward
to the best tip which is 30 you can see
how it slowly transforms from red to
green i like that a lot just because it
feels much more interactive and dynamic
now compared to what we had before all
right so let's give it one one last try
we're gonna put in 99 here for the bill
and then
as i
scrub you can see how everything updates
appropriately if i backspace there's no
crash
i can enter in another amount and
everything works just as we expect
awesome so if this is your first ever
android app that's amazing
congratulations let me know in a comment
the reason i really like the tip
calculator that there's so many ways you
can extend this basic project that we
have to make it more interesting so a
couple ideas i had number one you could
split the bill by end people so you
could imagine that you go out to dinner
with a number of people you add in three
or four and then you should divide that
total amount by
three or four in order to make it easy
for everyone to pay a certain amount
second you could add a button or some
sort of component which allows the user
to round the final amount up or down so
there's no need to deal with change
and of course there's a lot more that
you could do in terms of design or color
updates
so what i recommend now is complete any
number of extensions either the ones
that we talked about or something that
you came up with on your own and then
you can more or less publish exactly
what you have on the play store i won't
walk through that here but i'll leave a
video in the description where i talk
about how to do that
and i hope that you use this tip
calculator as a starting point in your
journey as an android developer and you
build many more apps in the future
if you enjoyed this please drop a like
and comment
would love to hear from you thanks so
much for watching and i will see you in
the next one
bye
[Music]